cristiana reali la mère de votre enfant
l'a pris comment serge je peux avoir ma
petite lumière là alors c'est la
question qui tue francis huster et à la
question qui fâche comme disent certains
copieurs c'est au sujet des j'adore la
vie christiane à vous a dit quoi
franchement elle vous a dit quand elle a
vu le spectacle
elle vous a dit quoi je suis tu es
complètement con elle avait vu en
festival c'est l'avait trouvé ça
formidable comme un crétin j'ai fait
trois erreurs le soir de la générale y
avait un micro avec une réverbération
dans la sage d'épouvantables on a
l'impression de parler devant derrière
en plus ça m'avait dit de me méfier de
tous les sketches de paysans j'en ai
trois ou quatre espaces oise est pas mal
mais jouer tactique bio et voilà alors
voilà au bout de deux ans on en a marre
et puis la troisième chose c'est
qu'effectivement j'aurais peut-être dû
commencer la trilogie avec la peste
elle a trouvé que j'avais des couilles
d'arrêter mais elle n'était pas très
chaude pour le spectacle ah non non non
elle le trouvait trop si c'était de la
folie
trop risqué donc elle vous aime on
rallume missionnaires et
et francis huster bien raconter les
chercheurs ou la distribution dans la
tente d'ailleurs vous pouvez lui dire un
questionnaire on vous attend il paraît
qu'elle a un petit peu peur de moi alors
je vous le dit christiane asham et
gauche sont sympas c'est vrai bien